Instagram's free
in marketing do you know how insane that
is go try to call the newspaper of this
[__] town and ask them to put an ad
in the paper for free
go run a commercial on seven for free
go get a billboard on these nice little
streets out there for free
shut the [__] up
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you
what's good
thank you
[Applause]
Brizzy
happy to be here
oh this all right
well I'll Stand let's stand
[Applause]
okay we're in a city Brisbane where
shout out the pandemic they'll hit by
twice a lot of businesses went
underground and the floods just
literally killed them how do you how do
you have the right mindset when
uncontrollables kind of take over and
out of the job what's an interesting
question I think you know this is why
I'm so
passionate about gratitude
right you know I think I think that
most humans complain about dumb [__]
and then something real happens and you
realize how dumb it was
and so you know when life throws you
very challenging moments
the places I go are well one you had no
choice right it's not like you could
predict that a flood was going to come
and do these horrible things you have to
adapt to reality everybody here in their
life will be met with real challenges
you know God willing most people live a
long life which also then comes along
with losing people that you love so much
you know I think many people have all
agreed around the world that the
scariest thing in life is losing a child
many people will go through that there
are always challenges but I think when I
hear that question my brain goes into
two places deep deep gratitude for
waking up every day and that not
happening and I think people struggle
with enjoyment in the Simplicity of that
which is why I push it so hard I can
tell you it is foundational to my
happiness
you know when I wake up this morning I'm
not thinking about how cool it is to
have an audience like this come out for
me on a Saturday you know how humbling
this is do you know how grateful I mean
it's I love you back
but it's this is a Saturday like [__]
you know like thank you but I don't
think about that I don't think about
that video I watch almost predominantly
embarrassed you know really I mean it
that's not what I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about like when I woke up like
oh good another day when nothing crazy
happened and I think that way every day
and then when things do happen that are
challenging ironically the first place I
go is gratitude for the fact that it
doesn't normally happen or it hadn't
happened before and then I go into
getting my stomach punched and dealing
with the reality of it and trying to
lead and clean up and fix and try to
make things better for tomorrow because
you have no choice I don't see a whole
lot of value in dwelling or you know I
think that there should be room for
space for you to you know go through the
pain you know I think a lot of people
put up a front especially with a death
or something extreme like you should
have some breathing room to mourn
and you know deal with that but to dwell
and complain
is the least thoughtful and strategic
energy in the world and right now we
have a lot of dwelling and complaining
normally about [__] you can't control
that actually isn't [__] you up it's
the dwelling and complaining that's
[__] you up
your parents
I mean
they had sex at the right second
so that you know that's a big deal
um so I got to give him a lot of props
for that
um my mom is an all-time mom she built a
mindset in me that
I feel like I would actually argue that
what I'm doing here right now is trying
to scale what my mom did for me for
society because it's so clear to me that
she deserves an extraordinary amount of
the credit
not only do I share a lot of her DNA she
also cultivated me she was my core
parent
and then when I got a little bit older I
started working my dad's store and he
put in some incredibly strong principles
into me because he's a very honorable
man and you know this is why I'm not
embarrassed about the video or about
what's going on with me because I don't
really think me is me I think me as my
parents and my circumstance and the
reality of where I came from and how it
like I'm the byproduct
I I I'm really not attached to the me of
it all I do like the things I built
because I feel like I'm cultivating
those things my mentorship the companies
I build but it's really easy for me to
give all I mean at some level brother
all of it
like I really struggle to think about
like my like I'm proud of my hard work
and like the things I've done but I also
know how much of that was instilled in
me so I'm I'm a huge byproduct of them
you mentioned many different chapters
and your early entrepreneurial kind of
stuff you were doing yes
well I'm just hanging with some
individuals in Green Room I was talking
about like there's a lot of people like
Gary you know I'm about to start this
business and I'm scared to fail and my
brain always goes into like you're
probably gonna fail
especially if you've never done business
before like watching entrepreneurship
and business get cool in the last 10 15
years has been frightening
like most of the beautiful faces I'm
looking at here right now have not put
in the practice nor have the talent to
actually do it
but that's not bad
not bad that's actually Epic
if you actually go into it knowing
you're gonna fail
and so you know what I mean
because all I ever did as a kid was
business of and I had natural talent in
it of course this happened
you know many people stay students and
athletes
for the predominant part of their life
as a child and then they go to more
school and then they go to real life
and they're confused to why it's hard
it's because you haven't lived real life
yet
you've been playing in a fake
environment and so
I learned all the mistakes at six and
eight and ten and thirteen and twelve
and 14 and 19 and 23 and I still make a
shitload
but if you've not trained at all for a
marathon how the [__] are you gonna run
and so for a lot of people here who are
deciding to run for the first time in an
environment like that
should whether you're 20 30 40 50 60 70
80 but to go in with audacity that you
think it's going to work when you never
trained is [__] insane
and so like people always roll up and be
like garyvee like at the airport garyvee
so [__] bro I'm gonna build a billion
dollar company I'm like all right like
you know if I ask them one question
they're like no not yet but I'm like and
I'm like then you're probably not
and that's okay
like I think people have
what to put on a pedestal all [__] up
you know a billion dollar company like
that's for point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of people
like
how about enjoying the process of
building a company and hoping it doesn't
go out of business
because if you pull that off you're
[__] remarkable
because 99 of people got a business
[Applause]
practice
like this is the biggest problem with
modern parenting
we think it's good to keep kids away
from pain
yeah of course like I only like kids
that cry after they lose
[Laughter]
like this concert like don't cry it's
just a game [__] you Mom
Life's a game like eighth place trophies
like these leagues that have popped up
that don't get winners what the [__] are
we doing
like we need you know you we said it
yesterday and I'll say it again here
like I think every kid should get into
at least one fight
like I don't think you're a real man
until you get punched in the [__]
face
you know and you know like and then
we're just over coddling an entire
generation
I I'm so tired of gen xers and Boomers
[__] on gen Z
you are the one who parented them
[__]
like parents come up to me all the time
like Gary my [__] kid like you gotta
talk to him like he's just off I'm like
you stop paying his rent
you you want your 20 plus year old to be
better don't give them money
like we're just we got it all backwards
like we're micromanaging them you don't
need to know where they are at every
second
when I was eight in New Jersey in 1983
my mom had no [__] clue where I was
I was on the [__] train tracks like
oh here comes the train uh push your
friend like we were doing all sorts of
things I'd pick up a stick and like hit
my friend
and that's why we have resilience do you
know what happens to zoo animals when we
all tell them to free like not like
people get mad sometimes like [__]
this is [__] up free the zoo animals
they shouldn't be in cages do you know
what happens they put them in the wild
and they die within a minute
they're not ready for the jungle parents
I'm telling you get out of your kids
business let them paint a little bit
and it's [__] crazy out here like
your kids like like okay like parents
take their kids to the [__]
playground a kid pushes them and the
parent jumps in and wants a fight
kid gets a D in school and the parent
goes to school and now fights about
grades get out of your [__] kid's
[__]
yeah let them get beat up
promise or teach them how to fight
is that parenting or you think has
caused a lot of people to kind of doubt
themselves yeah
[Music]
and how do you grow confidence
by living actual life and realizing
there's nothing wrong with it like
losing is great
like all like this is losing
like what are you scared of like what's
gonna happen like you don't mean people
here like Gary I want to make like we're
about to do q a Gary I want to post but
I'm like I'm like what's gonna happen
your sister's gonna text you and say you
look like an idiot
like you're you're gonna only get three
views
and you're gonna be upset like what's so
scary
everyone keeps living their entire adult
life like they're still in high school
like yes I think that parents are over
coddling but but then you become here's
my point and then you're 25. like this
is where I'm very hot on the parenting
thing but then there's another part of
them there's the other side of the
pillow yes I understand your parents did
this and yes I understand they did that
but now you're 25.
exactly you're 25 Now You're Gonna Keep
crying about Mommy and Daddy or are you
going to stand on your own feet go to
therapy start working out start
meditating start surrounding yourself
with positive people like when are you
gonna stop blaming them
there's grown-ass 50 year olds in here
blaming their whole life on their
parents
okay and what
you're just gonna blame them your whole
life and then die
how about accountability
so yes do I think it happens yes nature
and nurture was figured out long before
I was on Earth
my question is what are you gonna do
about it
I talk about loving my parents and
they're awesome and a lot of people here
follow me and know that and I can sit
here the rest of my life telling you
what they did wrong I just don't have
the energy to think about it I focus on
what they did right
yeah I focus on what they did right
I mean like like how many people here
have followed me for more than three
years raise your hands thank you so you
have an incredible my parents and I sit
around and have dinner and just laugh
about this
yeah they're like they're like I'm more
very close they're like man you've
really made us out to be [__]
insanely awesome
like you know like I just don't know how
to focus on what they've done wrong I
could I could if I like try to focus I
can tell you
and of course I thought about it
I just don't know what to do with that
energy
what what are you gonna what
and by the way like I said a v con
their parents [__] them up I get so
mad when my friends and acquaintances
and co-workers are like my mom's [__]
up but my granny's awesome and then I
met the granny and I'm like the granny
[__] up the line
your granny is a piece of [__] you just
didn't you just didn't see her that
often
you know I just I just don't understand
the blame game the dwell game I
understand it because 99 of Earth walks
around and lives in it I just would
prefer them to get out of it because
I don't know like
living a happy life is a much better
idea than
not
cool
I mean [__] man I lost a lot like
I I mean look I've I've when I think
about my life
until I was like 14 if I lost in any
game I would cry for an hour
anything
absolutely anything
and
and lots of things like I peed my bed
until I was like 12.
and like was petrified of that like was
scared to go to like sleepovers because
I'd be like man if I piss my bed in this
situation
this could be it
um I lost I I much like Muhammad Ali and
Joe Frazier I had a Trilogy fight with
Odette Weinstock and I lost the middle
one in junior high because he pushed me
into a locker and the code hit my ribs
and [__] me up and then he jumped on
top of me and then the teachers came and
then I got that was kind of like a small
scrimmage but I got to [__] lunch and
everyone's like Odette beat up Gary and
I was like [__] and that was like
horrible like I can't we had a fight
after school and I revenged my loss and
so
I mean I I had a thousand I mean a
thousand dollars in baseball cards have
one show and then
like the money burned a hole in my
pocket you know you don't have a car
when you're 14 as we all know and my mom
went to Costco and they had these cards
there and they were shitty cards and I
knew it
but I didn't have the discipline yet to
be patient and I spent all one thousand
dollars on buying all the boxes because
I couldn't wait to get home and open all
the packs and I got nothing
I got 18 15 100 worth of cards out of
all those boxes and I kind of had to
start all over to build up my game and
that was devastating that's a lesson
that is a lesson of like don't let the
money burn a hole in your pocket don't
buy dumb [__] or it might not work out I
mean I could sit here for I mean tons of
losses I I mean I would argue the like
in the way that people think about life
I would say the first 12 years of my
career were a loss I worked 15 hours a
day every day seven days a week built a
business for someone else and had to
start vaynermedia in a conference room
at 34 years old of another company
because I didn't have enough money to
have pay for rent now that person was my
dad so it makes it better but I didn't
make any money for what I created
I'm always losing
I shouldn't even be here
no I'm being dead serious actually
this trip is not really mathematically
right for me
but that's not what I value I'm not
trying to extract the most amount of
cash value I miss being in Australia so
I want it to come
you understand
I wanted I love supporting young
entrepreneurs you're trying to do
something I'm aware that me being here
is a platform for you to do the next
thing it's not it's not I don't think
the way most people think
so when people say like what are your
losses you know this like I think
nothing and I think everything
I don't think anything's been a loss
because nothing atrocious has happened
and then I can sit here and tell you
another 57 stories of [__] that went
wrong in the way that people think like
do you know many people are sitting
right now here and around the world
saying if I just made that decision
three years ago different everything
would be better
do you know how crazy that is
if I [__] there's people sitting here
right now being like I shouldn't have
married this [__] person or I
shouldn't have taken this job or I
should have invested in that or I should
have bought that property or I should
have joined my parents business I
shouldn't have joined all people are
doing are looking backwards
looking backwards [__] up your neck my
friends
I also don't know if you know this
Brizzy but I have some shocking news
there's no such thing as a time machine
spending time of what the mistake you
made seven years ago is a problem you
can't walk into a machine and go back
it's [__] over
it's over
and the only people that are listening
to you complain about it are other
people that are losing
yep
what's the difference between patients
and getting involved complicity there
are two different words Ethan
and I like what you're doing you're
taking you know the the prior to
interviews and you're adding it to here
so I like what you're doing right now
because the I like that you picked up on
me talking about that the last two times
they're two different words
like but people interpret
how they want to
yeah in life one of the most fascinating
things is you find what you're looking
for
you will find what you're looking for my
friends
this is why I laugh when everybody
blames the algorithms
the algorithms are [__] us up
your pessimism is [__] you up
when I open my phone the first video is
a boy saving a cat in a tree
the next one is a mom loving a son the
next one is sunshine is good the next
one is like life is awesome I'm not
seeing what you're seeing because I'm
not [__] spending my time on what
you're spending your time on
you're in control of your algorithm
oh and if you don't like it I don't know
if you heard you can delete it off your
phone
like people like you know in America
very politically going on other you got
your own [__] going on here like in
America like every four years if this
[__] guy wins the election I'm moving
to Canada
and in America we've had both
Republicans and Democrats and you know
I'm older now I've been through a bunch
of Elections news alert nobody's living
in Canada
and like and again if you don't like it
I don't know if you know this if you
don't like what's going on with in
Australia move [__]
we just don't have accountability
like [__] take control
everybody is just given up control the
government's [__] me up my mom's
[__] me up my boss [__] me up quit
your boss is [__] you up quit
well you don't get a Gary up like I do
get it quit you have less money I
understand
sell your house
and go rent
you put the pedestal of owning a house
on a pedestal over your own happiness
I do understand
you don't [__] understand
[Laughter]
ing
[Music]
strategy yes yes
tell us why and how you found the
emotional Improvement it happens and
flows I bet you know right now is I'm on
mindset
but like I'm sure of it that in three or
four years whether it's AI or VR
there'll be something so big that I'll
get hot on spending two years talking
about the tactics to take advantage of
the thing and for the people how many
people have been following me for seven
years or more just raise your hand thank
you and those people know that there's
times where I'm hot on this I spent the
whole year telling all of you to get on
tick tock four years ago most of you did
not listen
foreign
then I'm here then I'm here my job is to
react to what I'm feeling and reading
from all of you and then try to decide
what at the moment I can bring the most
value from and that's how I live my life
and so how did I get here
I started to realize wait a minute I can
tell you everything about Tick Tock but
if you're insecure to jump into a
platform that you think is too young for
you
well you're not going to do it
so I better start telling you why you're
doing that and so I'm just ebbing
flowing parenting
you know right like when you're how many
people here are parents right
all of us we ebb and flow
right like my mom continues to tell me
she's like I'm still gonna parent you
even though you're grown and like I get
it like it's a forever game
and
probably because I had such a great
parent I have this incredible
feeling to want to parent the world
and so I'm talking about this right now
because I'm watching all of you
give up control
you're blaming everybody
you've gotten really good at blaming
technology and government
and I don't think you should
because if you do and you think you're
not in control and can't do anything
about it you get sad
and sad is bad
is bad
because
you I don't know if you know this but
you were not born for a long time
like the world's been going on for a
long time before you showed the [__] up
and then you're gonna live
you're gonna die I don't know if you
know this and then the world's gonna go
on for a long time
you like that one it's true
my point is like okay so hey it's so
hard you know this is why that video 400
trillion to one went so viral for me
it's [__] crazy the odds at least
what the [__] scientists say I have
no [__] idea of being a human being
is 400 trillion to one
so what I know is as I look around here
like we won
right like back to my story about the
credit like maybe my mom would have had
a headache that night
I wouldn't exist
so my point is you've won the whole
[__] thing
you're gonna come on this Earth and just
dwell your way into death
[__] that [__]
one of the ingredients
well so I'm sitting up here with tons of
[__] you know bravado and feeling
great about my vision of like how life
should be and I had a big [__] hole
in my chest a real vulnerability and it
was called on stage what I've been doing
for the last 20 minutes Candor is my
strength
because I don't I'm looking at you as a
whole I'm not talking to an individual
person but in my life the more I loved
you the more I knew you
the more I struggled with giving Candor
I didn't want to hurt feelings I didn't
like the confrontation I struggled with
it enormously because I was able to
navigate around it I was always able to
find my own happiness and all the things
I'm talking about but what I didn't
realize was it was building resentment
and resentment is dangerous and so you
know between life events and work events
I got to a place in my early to mid 40s
where I realized that Candor was my
kryptonite
in all this happiness I'm a human too
and there was little things those were
easy but Candor was a big thing
you know I looked at a Facebook group of
former vaynermedia employees and
everyone was just [__] on me these
were the people that were most upset
with me these were the people that I
wasn't able to give feedback to that
they were bad and they were just stunned
when they got fired this was a hole this
was a vulnerability and I had a decision
to make
was I going to listen to the [__] I talk
about here on stage and take
accountability and fix it or was I going
to use all my success and happiness and
just look the other way and I chose the
latter because that's the better game
and it hurt it hurt to take on that
accountability it hurt when I feel like
I'm building the best culture and I have
all the best intent and I got to that
there are people that I've done wrong by
but it was because of Candor I thought
it was doing right by them by not
hurting their feelings but I was hurting
the ultimate feelings
and so candor's been a journey for me
when I finally got to this I I did to
myself what I do to the world I marketed
to myself I created this concept of kind
Candor and that felt comfortable that I
was going to give to Canada but I was
going to make it really nice
and really thoughtful and it's changed
the course of my life
and I think there's a lot of people who
struggle with Candor and I highly
recommend you realize how dangerous that
is
and you got to find a way whether it's
therapy couples therapy
um just practicing like I did the way
just for everybody like the way I fixed
it was now it was in my face before it
was subconscious
I was blind to it
when it became obvious to me through
that journey of that period in my life I
practicing I just started calling
meetings I mean I would literally email
someone like hey can I speak with you
for 15 minutes this one I went in one
year from somebody coming to me and
being like hey can you give me some
feedback is everything going well no and
I would be like this person stinks at
their job I'm like you're [__] epic
brecca like you're great I couldn't do
it to reaching out to people and setting
up 15 minutes and being like hey it's
not going well that's a big Journey
and I practiced and now
I still feel like nauseous when I know
I'm gonna have to fire someone the night
before things that nature but not the
same way because I know I've done a lot
of things along the way to at least not
making it shocking or inappropriate and
I'm really you know one of the reasons I
stand up here and push the things that
come out of my mouth is I know how hard
that was for me I know how hard physical
health was for me going to the gym and
eating right does not come natural to me
for [__] you saw the videos 10 years ago
you know like but I've gone through a
journey I'm doing things that don't come
natural to me that I'm putting work into
and I'm fixing them I don't think I'm
special I think everybody in here can do
the same but first you have to see it
then you have to own it and then you
have to practice
[Applause]
it doesn't really affect you at the
moment what about someone that's in the
audience that kind of struggles with
somebody else to think about themselves
how they made how can they work on that
empathy
sympathy compassion the reason I don't
really struggle with people [__] on
me is
I feel bad for them
you know the concept of I'm going to go
around the Imagine waking up in the
morning opening your phone
looking through stuff figured by
something and and saying something that
you want to say to hurt someone
that's not happiness that's the complete
reverse
and so when I read like Gary you're full
of [__] none of this is true I'm not
feeling bad for me I'm feeling bad for
them
and so I think we don't have enough
compassion and empathy
you know like I really don't think
people have enough sympathy like I think
everything's about me me me me which is
why when you're like you're ugly you're
fat you're stupid you'll never achieve
it you're thinking about me instead of
saying then everything I do is about
them so when I see that I'm not thinking
about me I'm thinking about them and I'm
like why would someone do that
wow they're in such a bad place that the
only way they can deal with it is trying
to have someone else feel like them
they're in a full misery loves company
place
man I feel bad for them
compassion
one of the things you mentioned a lot of
things
for someone that wants to get better
than get better going to business but I
don't have that urgency haven't they
kind of instill that in other ways
you know I I don't think it's
urgency per se I mean it's one of the
variables I just think it's a lot of the
stuff we're talking about here which is
self-awareness is fascinating like
you know I think I I think a lot of this
comes down to posturing
you know like I want to go a step
further than that even like I just I
think a lot of people are doing [__]
and they don't even realize why
right like like getting better at
marketing is called practice
but also understanding that you might
not naturally be good at it
I could practice all I want in singing I
have a funny feeling if I started
singing half this room would be leaving
within the next five minutes
you know like like you can't like you
have to be self-aware you have to put in
the work like there's a lot of reasons
why someone would get better at
marketing but my question is why if
you're not good at it like why are you
not good at it have you not put in the
work
most likely but why didn't you put in
the work normally it's because you don't
like it
and so like now why are you doing it oh
you want the money because what you
think buying shit's gonna fix the Gap in
your heart
that's the [__] that's interesting to me
you know what I mean like people people
are completely commit people that don't
have money are completely convinced that
money is going to solve it
and they're wrong
they're wrong because what they should
be doing is find 10 people that they
know somehow someway that have lots of
money and they should hang out with them
as much as humanly possible for a year
and what they'll learn is it definitely
doesn't make you happy yeah and so I
just think that Society has gotten too
commercial
like what we put on a pedestal are the
wrong things people that have money
people have followers people have Fame
success it's fine
it's it's fine it's good it can be good
but man
we just really have to get back to
Basics around here like the reason most
of the people in this room are not good
at marketing is either it doesn't come
natural to them or they're doing it for
a reason that isn't the reason you know
and so
you know I think I don't think urgency
is going to make them better at it I
think practice makes you better at
everything but if you don't like
something you're not going to practice
there's some people here who've
practiced tennis
their whole life because they liked it
you know not because they thought they
were going to be Novak Djokovic
and and I think in work we don't see it
that way
the money conversations convoluted and I
think that more people would make more
money by doing [__] they like that
doesn't seem obvious that money is going
to come from it then doing things that
they think the money's in because
somebody's in real estate
and you go get a real estate license and
you become a real estate person if
you're not good at selling and you're
not passionate about real estate you're
going to fail
and so chasing where you think the money
is has led to a lot of people not making
money
a lot more uh you saw on that that's
values balance or are you like someone
below like
balance of [__] I just want to
actually balances
the place I stand on balance is I'm
asking everyone here who gets to decide
what balance is
people like Gary you know but you don't
have any work-life balance am I cool
John
tell me what work life balance is
like am I supposed to work nine to five
five days a week is that work-life
balance like who made up that [__]
like why not work nine to three three
days a week
France thinks so
you know like what's balance
and for me balance has ebbed and flow in
different ways there was parts of my
life where I wanted to work every minute
there was other parts where I didn't
because family Dynamics kicked in by the
way I never worked with New York Jets
play
I don't give a [__] if it's the most
important day of my business like the
three biggest speaking uh events I've
ever been offered I declined because the
Jets were playing
that's my balance I chose that I needed
those four hours of escapism of a
passion over the money bad financial
decision good emotional decision
balance
I just think that's
do you know what do you know why the
balance conversation even exists Ethan
laughs
the balance the word balance and work
life balance are very similar to another
word that I find very interesting
lucky
[Music]
and a lot and balance
are words that people that aren't doing
[__] use to weaponize to make themselves
feel better that aren't doing [__]
[Applause]
now for social media organic or
platforms right now I think anybody here
who how many people here are doing
social media content for themselves or
business or something of that nature
raise your hands raise them high I want
to get a sense
if you are not doing Facebook reels
you're missing a huge opportunity at
this exact second that's a humongous
platform I would argue most people are
not Facebook's a little forgotten for a
lot of people so Facebook reels is huge
organic similar to tick tock four years
ago you could have nothing very little
and post start posting what you're
posting on Instagram and tick tock on
Facebook reels and you will be
fascinated by how much organic reach is
there I think LinkedIn is wildly
underused by everyone here I think if
you're selling you know people think
LinkedIn is B2B business if you're
selling frisbees you should be posting
on LinkedIn
so I think LinkedIn is very good organic
reach and then I think those two are the
underpriced attention then the next
question becomes where the attention the
reach is fair then it becomes a game of
best
right so one of my favorite other
excuses Ethan is like people dming me
like Gary I need your help I'm Shadow
banned
when I click there you know this is the
weird [__] I do brother then I click
their account and look at their content
I'm like ah got it go back to the DM hey
brother you're not Shadow band you just
suck
everybody here wants to blame the
algorithm oh I'm not getting as much
reach on my Facebook on my Instagram
they just want my they just want ads
they want the money no no
the reach was free
I love everyone's like these platforms
it's free like you post and people see
it and they don't charge you
yeah I'm just gonna say this nice and
slow Instagram's free
yeah in marketing
do you know what insane that is
go try to call the newspaper of this
[__] town and ask them put an ad in
the paper for free
go run a commercial on seven for free
go get a billboard on these nice little
streets out there for free
it's [__] free shut the [__] up
so back to the point
if it's free and everyone's there
then it becomes competitive
everyone's like oh there's too many
[__] people now that are influencers
I'm like yeah you're complaining because
you're one you're the problem
quit
it's called free it's called Merit it's
called survival of the fittest and
instead of crying about the algorithm or
all these other people how about getting
better at it
and better at it means knowing how to
title your videos what the thumbnail
needs to look like what the first three
seconds should look like the copy that
you support it with what time you post
it how you engage in the comments and
what are the platform differences of a
carousel versus a reels versus a
straight post and having a hook and like
how about realizing this is a skill
instead of dumb [__] luck
and what about putting in the hours of
reading and testing and working to be
good at it
or you can blame the algorithm
[Music]